what would happen if all hashira fought
yorichi together would they be able to
defeat him or would he absolutely
destroy them within seconds well you
probably think that the shiras have no
chance against this monster but is that
really true although yorichi did defeat
muzon pretty quickly it's important to
remember that even he is not Invincible
he was scared while battling him and he
even said to himself that if he got hit
even once he would be dead it's also
important to remember that fighting one
strong enemy is not the same as fighting
multiple weaker ones in this scenario
yorichi would have to keep his eyes on
10 different enemies simultaneously each
with their unique breathing style
another thing to keep in mind for this
fight is that we never saw Sun breathing
used against human opponents it is
surely the strongest breathing style for
fighting demons since the sun is their
natural weakness but would it have the
same effect on hashiras okay before we
explain what exactly would happen in
this fight let's quickly see if there is
any hashira that could pose a problem to
yorichi out of all pillars in this
generation most of them have some kind
of unique ability or trick up their
sleeve take shinobu for example although
her physical strength and speed are
nowhere close to yorichi's levels she
actually has a deadly trick up her
sleeve poison with it she can kill
pretty much any demon really quickly
this can vary from a few seconds for
weaker demons and up to 30 or more
minutes for stronger ones like Doma
that's all pretty cool but what does
that have to do with yorichi you see
shinobu is a master of poisons as we saw
when she healed zinitsu from a deadly
demon poison and even helped tomayo
create a drug specifically made to
weaken muzon she even helped me create a
special subscribe poison that'll make
all of you instantly subscribe to the
channel okay the poison doesn't actually
work but it would still be great if you
subscribed thanks anyway if she ever had
to find a powerful swordsman like
yorichi she would most likely come up
with a unique type of poison that would
hurt yurichi the most and maybe even
kill him of course if she wanted to do
something like this she would have to
come close to yorichi and either slice
him with her poisonous sword or inject
him directly with a syringe this would
obviously be impossible for her to do
alone as yorichi would kill her long
before she even came close still this
ability would definitely come in handy a
bit later when all hishira attacked
yorichi together another hashira that
may be able to help in this fight with
his abilities is tenjin although the
sound pillar is incredibly strong and
possesses a unique breathing style it's
actually something completely different
that I want to talk about here you
probably noticed how demon Slayers don't
really care much gear around their
equipment usually consists of only their
sword or whatever other weapons they are
using well that's not the case with
tension throughout the Entertainment
District Arc we've seen him use all
kinds of interesting gadgets like kunai
explosive beads and even smoke bombs
although these things may not seem
especially strong I doubt yorichi ever
saw someone using these in his era to be
clear I am not saying tension would be
able to do any serious damage to yorichi
using these gadgets but at least he has
a chance to distract and confuse him for
a short period and possibly provide an
opening for his teammates creating an
opening in a battle like this is surely
really important but who will defend
hashiras from yorichi's insanely strong
attacks well this is where gyu comes in
but why him you see there are actually
two things Kyu can do to help pillars
gain an advantage in this fight first in
season 1 episode 20. we saw guiyu use a
water breathing technique we've never
seen before water breathing 11th form
Dead Calm the reason I am mentioning
this is that this technique was made by
gu himself and no other hashira
throughout history has ever used it this
means that yurichi would be completely
unaware of this technique and
probably managed to block some of this
attack now
can sit powerful yurichi is I doubt the
water pillar would be able to defend
himself and the others like this for
long this technique isn't impenetrable
and even akaza managed to break through
at one point regardless if he can hold
back to Richie even for a few seconds
using it it can tremendously help the
hashiras in this battle the second thing
I wanted to talk about when it comes to
guiyu is that his breathing style which
is based on water could theoretically
counter yorichi's fire-based breathing
style since as we all know water can
extend with fire I know this is a bit of
a reach but since we only saw demon
Slayers fight against each other a few
times we don't really know if breathing
Styles work this way anyway I thought
it's worth mentioning since it has at
least some chance of being true right
however one thing that is most certainly
true is that gyome is the strongest
pillar in the current generation he
literally unlocked every single ability
a Demon Slayer can unlock transparent
World Demon Slayer Mark selfless State
bright red weapon he has it all although
he doesn't possess any specific ability
that'll present a problem to yorichi I
believe he is the only pillar capable of
going head to head against him without
dying instantly I'm not saying it would
be a fair battle far from it gilmay
would surely end up sliced in pieces but
if he can hold him off just for a bit it
could be game changing for the hashiras
remember when I talked about guiyu and
how yarichi doesn't know about his
unique technique yeah well there are
actually whole breathing styles to
Richie doesn't know anything about and
would definitely catch him off guard if
you paid close attention while watching
Demon Slayer you probably noticed there
are six primary breathing Styles water
Moon flame Thunder Stone and wind this
means that every other breathing style
didn't exist in yorishi's Era and was
only developed Years Later by other
pillars so the Styles like Mist love and
serpent would probably work on yorichi
pretty well and confuse him as he never
saw them before mitsuri's fighting style
would probably surprise him the most as
he definitely won't expect her flexible
whip-like sword the only two pillars I
didn't mention so far are rangoku and
sonemi the reason for this is that I
don't think they have anything unique to
bring to the table in this battle
however that doesn't mean they won't be
able to do anything to help these two
are fun nominal offensive Fighters and
even though their abilities won't
surprise yurichi if they manage to catch
him off guard they can do some serious
damage to it okay after covering all
hashira's strengths and things that may
help him in this battle it's finally
time to ask the most important question
would all hashira together be able to
defeat the strongest Demon Slayer ever
yurichi tsuki Kuni for this battle to be
as entertaining as possible we'll assume
that both yorichi and the pillars are at
the peak of their strength this means
that rengoku and tenjin are still
members of the core and all others are
as powerful as they were in the infinity
Castle Arc which means that most of them
will have their Demon Slayer Mark along
with all other abilities they have
awakened as the final battle starts
hashiras waste no time and immediately
Rush towards yurichi asurichi prepares
to attack them tenjin throws his smoke
bombs which completely surprised the sun
breathing user as the dust clears the
hashiras have now completely surrounded
yorishi and are preparing to strike him
although they easily managed to get
close this isn't that good for them
since this also means that yorichi is
close to them I can attack them at any
time one thing that I want to remind you
of here is that although it doesn't seem
like it at times yorichi is just a human
and he can't regenerate his body if he
gets hit this means that even one Direct
Hit with one of the breathing styles
could be fatal for him anyway back to
the fight each Ashira prepares their
attack but before they they can land any
hit yorichi quickly activates
sun-breathing Raging Sun and
simultaneously slashes all hashira and
sends them flying away although this
attack wouldn't be powerful enough to
kill them all instantly it would surely
make them realize who they are up
against and that even one wrong move
could cost them their lives some of the
hashiras would enter the transparent
World in order to see yorichi's
movements more clearly while the others
would Clash their weapons with each
other to make them bright red with all
their strongest abilities now activated
they would rush towards urichi once
again in an attempt to quickly finish
him although tracking nine high-level
opponents simultaneously would be pretty
much impossible we are talking about
yorichi here the guy literally performs
all 12 Sun breathing techniques and hit
all of muzon's vital organs before the
demon even knew what had happened the
situation would probably be similar here
with yorichi swiftly slashing each Demon
Slayer with a different Sun breathing
form before they can even react with all
hishiras now seriously injured the
situation would seem hopeless for them
however these are the pillars we are
talking about here and if there's one
thing they know how to do it's pushing
themselves to the absolute limits the
remaining Warriors would stand up again
ready to face yorichi they would realize
that if they want to get close to him
without dying they must better
coordinate attacks and use their
abilities more strategically this time
du would go first next to him would be
Albany who would use his incredible
perception abilities to guide others in
avoiding yorichi's attacks along with
muichiro who would try to distract
urichi by creating a thick Mist behind
him behind them would be all other
pillars ready to attack urichi head-on
as soon as they see the chance yurichi
would once again prepare his Sun
breathing abilities and jump toward the
pillars however this time yiyu who is
going first would activate his Dead Calm
technique in order to buy pillars some
time this would only give them a few
seconds as urichi's immense power would
quickly overwhelm giu and break through
his technique however immediately after
Kyu Falls muichiro activates his final
form and creates a thick Mist around
yorichi completely obscuring his vision
at that point all remaining hashiras
would jump into the smoke with their
strongest technique to quickly kill him
while he is not expecting it using the
transparent world yorichi would sense
some of the hashiras and would also
prepare his strongest attack Sun
breathing 13th form as all attacks Clash
a huge explosion complete destroys their
surroundings and leaves nothing but a
big crater in the center as the dust
finally clears all hashiras can be seen
lying dead on the floor while yorichi is
on his knees heavily injured but still
alive in the end even the combined
efforts of all the strongest Warriors
from the current generation weren't
enough to bring down this monster click
on this video where we explained what
would happen if nezuko became a demon
instead of tanjaro